Hello and welcome to this AI Coffee Break!
Recently, we have seen how Transformers
are being applied not only on text,
but on images or even on both combined!
How is it possible?
Aren’t images and text so different? We read text
from left to right and images are something that
we perceive at once.
Or do we?
In this video, we will explain why images
and text can be similar in the “eyes”
a Transformer neural network and point out
what really makes images and text different;
difference that could make
the Transformer stumble.
On the representation level: What is text?
Text is a sequence of characters or words.
And it’s a sequence, because we read
from left to right (in English).
But neural networks do not work
directly with characters nor with text.
Neural networks work with points
determined by coordinates, or
numbers in high dimensional spaces.
Neural networks are great at squeezing,
stretching, and bending the input space so that
the similar data points get close together and are
easy to discriminate from dissimilar data points.
So the Transformers working with numbers, request
that characters or words are encoded into vectors.
These vectors are ordered, preserving the
sequence structure of the text. There are neural
architectures, like the LSTM, where this order
is captured intrinsically by the architecture:
The LSTM does look at every
word vector one after the other.
But the Transformer works on sets,
looks at everything in parallel,
so for the Transformer to know this order,
positional embeddings are added to the vectors.
The vectors can be initialized with
numbers where words belonging together
are already together, or they can be
one-hot encodings or token identifiers.
It is always up to the loss-constrained
neural network to figure out a better,
inner representation where words belonging
together are shifted closer to each other.
And that was it for the text,
the rest is Transformer magic,
check out our video explaining how
the Transformer works linked below!
Then what are images? Grayscale images
are a matrix of numbers. A high number
corresponds to a high light intensity in
that region. A low number is a darker spot.
For color images we just have a
stack of three of these matrices,
each corresponding to the
red, blue and green channel.
A high number in the red matrix corresponds
to a high intensity of red light.
But once the image is stored, the computer has
these three matrices and the color
is not exactly there anymore.
The computer would not notice if we would just
exchange the numbers between these matrices.
Colour occurs again in your monitor:
if there is a high value in the matrix
labelled with red, it will emit light with
the certain light frequency that we call red.
So let’s look at the word vectors again:
If we take their sequence and put them one
under the other, we have… an image! Crazy right?
Let’s undo this again and do
something different instead:
Take the image and treat
it like a sequence of rows.
And this idea is not that crazy, it is exactly how
cathode-ray tube screens in old TVs and old
monitors treated this matrix as a sequence by
“drawing” the image from left
to right and from top to bottom!
In this way, the representation
of text and images is the same:
the text is a sequence of word vectors,
the image is a sequence of image vectors.
We can add positional embeddings and
a Transformer is ready to process text
or images individually or both at the
same time for multimodal integration.
And the Transformer can process them quite
efficiently because computations are in
parallel on this set of vectors, which
is not really a sequence, it's a set.
The sequentiality is quite artificially
encoded in these positional embeddings.
In this way Transformers kind of butcher the
way we humans thought about text and images.
We are comfortable with the LSTMs inductive
bias of looking at one word after the other.
So why is the Transformer looking
at everything at the same time?
Well, I do not know about you, but
for me, when I am reading out loud,
I have to peek much further away into
the sequence to get the right intonation.
I also peek into the past by
short-term memorization which is
honestly better than the memory of the LSTM.
We are also comfortable with
CNNs that do a very similar
kind of processing as what happens in our eyes.
But applying these kind of biological
inspiration on neural networks and
restricting their solution space
with biases is also unfair to them.
It is important to take as much inspiration
from the biological optimization algorithm,
especially when it comes to energy
efficiency, but we should also look beyond,
like with the Transformer that is free
of the LSTM and CNN inductive biases.
Ok, so we have seen that images and
text can be represented the same and
the Transformer heavily takes advantage of this.
But if images and text are represented
equally, does that make them equal?
Well, no, images and text are
not born equal. Therefore,
they become very different content-wise:
Vision is often an evolutionary necessity
and evolved independently in many species.
Language, human’s stroke of genius came
later, after humans already had their vision.
Being invented it is based
upon many agreed-upon rules,
therefore text is in a way already
compressed; it omits a lot of stuff:
we do not say that the grass is green,
if it is a (visual) common knowledge.
Also, in the datasets Transfomers are usually
trained on, there is little if no figurative
speech and there are very few ways to say
for example “cat” in English language.
In contrast, images of cats can look very,
very different from each angle,
camera setting and so on.
So omission of the visual information in language,
the necessary and somewhat arbitrary rules of
language, cultures and languages (plural),
are few of the many things that make text
and images quite different in content: There
is overlap, but they are also complementary.
And Ms. Coffee Bean thinks that this is so
exciting that the representations and the
processing is similar, but the content and
nature of text and images are so different:
When the transformer acts on language, we
sometimes do not see the language phenomena
because of so much transformer complexity
and the other times we do not see the
transformer because of so much language.
So it's the more helpful to learn something
about transformers, text and images by seeing
them interact in different constellations.
It's more or less like a
complicated ablation study.
And the takeaway for multimodal
integration of all these three together,
is that even if text and images are
represented the same, they are not equal
in their content, giving Transformer
models a hard time to integrate them.
The tendency is to kind of ignore the
visual information and rely on the text,
because text is already so compressed and
it's biases are more easy to be picked up.
To find out more about this vision
and language inequality and its
effects on multimodal learning, check
out our video about this linked below.
In any case, Ms. Coffee
Bean is out of here. Right?
Hey, Ms. Coffee Bean?
Ms. Coffee Bean!
Ms. Coffee Bean, come!
Ok bye!